oui mais c'est déjà prévu moi la villa
est déjà loué
une grande chambre la plus belle
je vais venir plus que
bien sûr
compte 10 contre 10 il y a 5 filles et
quatre garçons et donc toi ça fait plus
de voix
est-ce que je peux avoir un stylo s'il
vous plaît
il faut vraiment que j'arrive à
comprendre ces vacances
on est d'accord donc il y a quatre
filles
cinq filles quatre garçons plus moi
voilà on est 10 5 garçons alors au
niveau des filles et des garçons
parce qu'il y a cinq garçons donc 5
filles tout à fait est-ce qu'il y a des
crossover
ou bien les garçons crossent ensemble et
les non alors sur les garçons il n'y a
pas de d'hétérosexuel il n'y a que des
des homosexuels
[Applaudissements]
sur les quatre garçons qui sont les
garçons
je suis en train
dans une maison
donc il y a cinq garçons
et célibataire célibataire et moi un
héros
[Rires]
c'est la question que je me pose
[Applaudissements]
parce que je suis maqué par contre
destrier ah alors tu te rends compte je
vais me régaler par contre toi
j'aimerais galérer
est-ce que c'est vrai cette histoire
mais bien sûr oui c'est vrai non mais
arrête je te dis je loue une villa et
voilà je j'ai quand même
cette année c'est du premier au 10 août
premier au 18 juin
pourquoi vous allez pas avec votre
compagne comme ça c'est l'occasion de
rencontrer des bonnes idées
on amène jamais sa saucisse à Strasbourg
[Applaudissements]
faire des amis des copines
ça suffit bon en tout cas
on se parle aux alentours de 21h20
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mon mot à dire sur mes invités
tu penses que non mais tes copines aussi
attends
je pense que je suis pas sûr qu'on leur
plaise ah oui et puis tes copines toi je
sais déjà qu'elle a deux c'est sûr que
tu
as fait les trois autres je vais sonder
mais il y a moyen de moyenne bien sûr
c'est du premier audition
du premier au 10 août mais tu peux venir
même 5 6 jours c'est suffisant
c'est déjà oui c'est déjà ça donc tu es
en train de me dire récapitulons que tu
me proposes des vacances dix jours tout
frais payés avec
la princesse
on va rigoler toute la journée sportif
en plus je suppose oui on va pouvoir
faire du sport
défi très sportif très sympathique tout
ça et tout payé par toi tout à fait
rigoler bien sûr qui refuserait ça
la plus beaux endroits de mykono
vous allez visiter la Grèce on est
toujours à l'antenne
[Rires]
[Musique]
on s'entend très bien tous les deux on
se kiffe uniquement pour ça vraiment je
vous jure que c'est vraiment et voilà et
si je prenne moi tu me connais je suis
un fou d'amitié moi avec que des copains
à la maison
franchement pareil je suis on va rigoler
facilement même du coup alors moi je
vais vous dire le ce que je passe en
numéro 1
et là je pense que nous on va rigoler et
on va être ami en numéro 2 c'est l'amour
avec je voulais pas le dire mais après
c'est le sport
par contre toi
et venez vous faites juste une base
mais si tu es sur le bateau de Cyril ça
va alors
[Rires]
un texte maintenant il peut venir lui
directement chez toi
je pense que tes copines pourraient qui
fait Gilles ou pas ah non mais Cyril
arrêtez j'ai rien dit je viens gentiment
j'ai préparé mes sujets là vous mettez
dans un bourbier
[Applaudissements]
mes amis me parle de Siri c'est normal
ah oui voilà donc il y en a qui me
disent oui bah si il est sexy j'aime
bien kaarismatique
[Applaudissements]
vous avez besoin d'un weekend drôle
c'est qui c'est tes copines qui disent
et c'est un félicite t'as pas un prénom
comme ça bah alors j'ai toujours et
encore Margaux alors je vais faire le
test tu éteins le test
ils vont toute mon entre 30 et 35 ans
pour lui le sport
célibataire et vraiment on recherche de
d'amour elle aime la vie Charlène
d'amour est généreuse le sport le don de
soif
généreuse donc de soi c'est toujours
sympa
toujours sympa alors Charlène
ah oui
du premier au 10
[Applaudissements]
et donc coach
sportifs
heureusement que je suis tu vois sérieux
mais lui va venir au-delà
les jours fériés
[Rires]
un partenaire de séduction
[Applaudissements]
depuis les dernières années à tous les
niveaux le corps la barbe le visage les
la tenue tout est
tout le monde est d'accord là dessus
c'est non
je suis pas là dedans je vais vous dire
franchement
bien sûr
j'aimerais bien être encore comme vous
là au top de la séduction
j'ai mis un terme définitif à toute vie
sexuelle
c'est fini je vais même plus longtemps
de parler ça me dégoûte mais c'est
franchement je suis content pour les
autres et pour moi non
rien c'est fini
non mais sérieux c'est fou vraiment il
est sérieux il m'en a parlé en fait
c'est vrai il a il a dit ça il stoppe
retourne
pour bien faire franchement
[Applaudissements]
la dernière chance comme ça voilà
mais j'y vais entraînant des pieds
tu as pas envie cet été je vais tirer
des corners à la Rémoise comme ça
rentrant
[Applaudissements]
oubliez moi avec vos conneries
je vais t'envoyer Raymond et Guillaume
et Jean-Mi ça va être magnifique et
Gilles
[Applaudissements]
benjaminer
tout de suite
[Rires]
courant 2025